Amber Heard just announced that she's
gonna be a part of yeah and the Aquaman
series yet is it like having another
woman in Justice League I love it I hope
that we all get to work together at some
point because women's sometimes in these
films don't get to actually be on set
together at the same time I've met her
before she's a great woman and and I
think that she and gal and I are gonna
have a blast if we get to so I love
working with women for me I'm used to be
working with men most of the time and
working with women is just so refreshing
and I'm so happy about that
and I'm happy that Amber is gonna be our
new addition et exclusively broke the
news that Amber Heard was joining the
Justice League as Mira on Thursday
you're playing Mira have you tried on
costume yeah yeah it's is graphic can
you tease it a little bit I'm wearing
like a it's like half suit of armor half
scale I don't know it's a strange it's
strange but we're building it we're in
the process of building it nails so come
on